halo was a series many have grown up
with i was one of those people too but
not in the traditional sense i didn't
have those days of joining my friends
during lunch at school and talking about
the newest release i mean in a more
literal sense halo ce released when i
was 1 years old fast forward to today
and now i'm in my early 20s awaiting the
newest release halo has always had a
special place in my heart as it was the
very first game i ever played i was 6
when i explored the vast world of halo's
rings i never made it past this point as
i was terrified of the covenant back
then but over the years i would come
back and get engulfed in its universe
and play its future releases while that
is just my story i'm not the only one
who's had this experience halo is a
gaming phenomenon the master chief is
not only the face of xbox but a face of
the gaming industry the same time the
original xbox would hit shelves was the
same day that halo ce would join it xbox
and halo have been inseparable for 20
years and they'll probably continue to
be for a very long time so today in
preparation for halo infinite and my
eventual video reviewing halo infinite
i'll be going over the main installments
of the halo franchise in hopes of taking
trips down memory lane and seeing how
the games held up were they the iconic
classics that still deserve the praise
they received or were they only good
until the nostalgia wore off
whatever they may be you'll just have to
wait and see
welcome to the halo series retrospective
let's get started
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
halo's beginnings started with bungie
but bungie's beginnings weren't always
with halo bungie was founded in 1991 and
was originally in the process of making
a game called marathon after some
moderate success the company's members
would meet to discuss further entries in
the marathon series until co-founder
jason jones would propose a new idea
that was a first-person shooter one that
could be seen as the natural extension
to marathon but while designing the game
the team enjoyed the concept of
vehicular combat so much that they
dropped the fps style of their game and
turned it into a real-time strategy game
in hopes of attracting more of an
audience to their game bungie would
reach out to steve jobs and ask to see
what they've been making having been
impressed by the product he would
premiere it at the 1999 mac world expo
still missing a name for the project
their first choice was the name covenant
until the company finally decided on
halo during the expo was announced that
halo would release on mac and windows
computers but microsoft had some better
ideas up their sleeves less than a year
later in march of 2000 microsoft would
announce its newest creation the xbox
microsoft would shortly after begin
buying small studios to add to their
gaming division one of these studios was
bungie the xbox while announced at the
time wouldn't be officially revealed to
the public until january 3rd of 2001.
microsoft would also announce that halo
would be releasing alongside the console
on november 15th bungie at the time was
still just a small company of 15
developers and in terms of progress they
only had a few rough ideas for what they
wanted halo to be but now they had to
make a full game in less than a year
decisions needed to be made fast so
jason jones would change the game back
to a first person shooter as he believed
it would feel better when played on a
controller the rest of the team was also
beginning to work overtime on the
project level designers and artists were
collaborating with each other in order
to get things finished on time and they
also hired music composer martin
o'donnell to create the soundtrack for
the game and while its development was
rushed what they created was nothing
short of perfection
or at least that's what they had hoped
reception of the game at e3 2001 was
mixed as many critics were upset over
the decision to move halo to a new
console and many consumers who tested
the game reported poor frame rates and
massive technical issues despite the
initial criticism halo would eventually
release in a much more stable state
which not only captured the hearts of
fans but its critics it is credited as
modernizing the fps genre and the reason
for xbox's success it was also praised
across numerous magazines for its
balance of weaponry and intelligent ai
but that was back in 2001. what about
today
despite halo ce being 20 years old it
still feels great to play to this day
and that's what makes the game so iconic
it was revolutionary in its day standing
atop many who came before it but even
today it still has room to stand amongst
gaming's greatest most of this was
thanks to its brilliant attention to
combat as many critics said halo 1 had a
fantastic sense of balance in its
weaponry and its ai was unbelievable
each species of the covenant was
handcrafted and made to stand out from
one another and not just in design but
in its gameplay halo 1 introduced four
species of covenant through its 10
missions the grunts elites jackals and
hunters you can tell in its design alone
that each of them serve different
purposes on the battlefield the grunts
have always been considered a laughing
stock amongst fans as they will run away
from combat at the slightest
inconvenience but in a group they are
much more deadly jackals while just as
weak as a standard grunt come equipped
with a shield that blocks enemy fire
allowing them to create their own cover
this plasma shield is also extremely
weak against other plasma weapons but
very resistant to traditional firearms
which is perfect for dealing with the
unsc elites are on a more leveled
playing field to the player they are the
only enemies with a shield around their
armor and can deal a considerable amount
of damage the shield of an elite
functions very similar to a jackal's
plasma shield meaning bullets won't do
much good against them the elites also
have various ranks within their own
species some elites come equipped with a
standard loadout but as you move higher
up in the chain these elites come
equipped with much deadlier weapons and
abilities the hunters though are by far
the strongest enemy in the game able to
knock a player down with considerable
force any round put into the shield can
be ricocheted back to you and to top it
all off their most exposed area is their
back despite how strong the covenant can
be especially when they're grouped
together they do have their weaknesses
any plasma weapon can easily rip through
the shields of an elite or jackal
completely halting their defensive
capabilities hunters are quite simple as
long as you're willing to tango and the
grunts are
quite easy regardless of the situation
but halo combat evolved with its
intelligent ai will make any fire fight
engaging but more importantly rewarding
grunts being the smallest and weakest
among the group will run when their
numbers start to dwindle but other
tougher enemies like elites will not
enemies grouped into a corner is just
asking for a grenade but the covenant
will react and dodge out of the way of
incoming explosives if any covenant is
grouped with other members they'll more
than likely rush your position
especially if you're hurt on the other
side of the coin elites will back away
from engagements when injured so they
can recharge those shields behind cover
halo 1's ai at least on normal
difficulties is able to make any
engagement tough but rewarding not
something easy to breeze through without
thinking about you're constantly
managing your health your shield your
ammo capacity and enemy positions in
numbers no firefight ever felt cheapened
you succeeded and lived because you were
better not because the game let you win
this is further reinforced by halo's
extensive armory of weapons both the
covenant and unsc weaponry are not only
effective but fun to use quite rarely
will you gravitate towards only two
weapons as each serves a purpose in
combat the pistol is by far one of the
deadliest weapons in the game and can
pack a punch at any range while the
assault rifle is less focused on damage
and more on fire rate for other options
rather than just mowing down crowds of
ground troops the sniper can be used to
pick off tougher enemies from afar or
disable a turret and the rocket launcher
does exactly what you think it does as
for the covenant their weaponry is
incredibly unique the plaza pistol may
be seen as a terrible last resort weapon
but when fully charged can easily wipe
in elite shields with ease plasma rifles
are far greater in damage and stability
compared to its pistol counterpart but
lacks a quick way to remove shielding
other than firing the weapon both
however never need to be reloaded but do
have the potential to overheat and the
needler shoots pink crystals that hone
in on anything within its crosshairs
causing an explosive finish the beauty
of halo's weapons is that while some
weapons will be greater than others each
of them feels wonderful to use there has
never been a situation where i was upset
because i was given a plasma pistol in
fact there were numerous times i was
struggling to decide on what weapons to
use when all this comes together it
creates engaging fights that feel like
you won an award rather than a
participation trophy a great example is
in mission 5 where the chief is tasked
with assaulting halo's control room the
covenant have already beaten us here so
we need to push through their forces one
place you'll find yourself is the bridge
in front of you are a few sleeping
grunts and numerous other enemies ahead
being spotted causes all the grunts to
wake up and start combat but what is not
shown to the player right away is the
army of grunts on the other side of the
bridge who were also sleeping and now
becomes a very stressful encounter as
you're tasked with watching both sides
the grunts were put here is a way of
making combat challenging but never
impossible 90 of the time the grunts
will never do enough damage to severely
injure you they're not there to be a
constant force of damage against the
player though there more is an annoyance
furthermore the edges of the bridge are
just low enough that enemy fire from the
other bridge will hit you thankfully
there is much larger cover that protects
you but also exposes you to the bridge
you're currently on it's a constant back
and forth of hiding and shooting and
watching both sides to make sure no one
is flanking you after a few other
engagements deep into the structure
you'll come out on the other side of the
bridge this time more enemies have moved
in but you're already accustomed to this
sort of engagement so they keep the
enemies the same but add hunters to the
other side of the bridge you could opt
to take things slow and kill the hunters
first but now you're putting yourself at
another disadvantage as hunters excel in
close quarters and the enemies on the
opposite side of the bridge aren't
grunts but elites and jackals your best
course of action is just to stay on the
bridge and deal with the problems as
they come since the hunters won't be
killed as easily thanks to their shields
the game continually tries to challenge
you during combat by throwing different
combinations of enemies and putting you
in different environments that more than
likely puts you at a disadvantage this
exact style of gameplay continues with
the flood
sort of the flood is a complicated
subject they have new attack strategies
and patterns compared to the covenant
but due to the library being an almost
hour-long mission filled with linear
paths and waves of flood it's hard to
thoroughly enjoy your time with them the
introduction to the flood was done
exceptionally well liquid pus would drop
from the ceiling and hinting at
something happening and just about every
engagement with the covenant wasn't a
full frontal assault you were always
behind the enemy's line of defense which
makes things all the more confusing on
what exactly they're trying to defend
themselves from we first see them from a
helmet cam of a soldier before being
ambushed by another swarm of them
seconds after this introduction in the
following 20 minutes was captivating as
the game had introduced a third party in
the ongoing war between the humans and
the covenant this entire faction was the
spark of numerous questions and theories
about a possible alliance something that
would be explored in the later entries
it's such a shame though that the next
mission that they're in was a railroaded
sequence of similar corridors and awful
pacing that being said while the
library's gameplay was lacking in any
sort of engagement that doesn't mean its
story significance had suffered the
twist at the end of this mission that
the halo rings were not meant to destroy
the flood but instead everything else
was something i was completely
blindsided with it's still a wonderful
twist that was never told to the player
until the moment it needed to combat
evolves other story elements can best be
described as bare bones and simple but
in a good way it's the start of a brand
new series so deep lore concepts don't
need to be fully tapped into just yet
halo's plot is very similar to other
military science fiction media but
throughout its missions it will continue
to deepen relationships with the game's
characters and constantly try to push
itself away from the others master chief
from the very beginning is supposed to
be a super soldier he's the only person
in the game that's wearing this spartan
armor we're meant to see him as a one of
a kind soldier and extremely powerful
the master chief doesn't talk too much
throughout this game so it's really hard
to understand him however cortana is
completely different due to her talking
quite a bit throughout the game we
deepen our relationship with her just as
the chief is doing the same the chief in
a way is meant to symbolize us chief
wakes up in this covenant conflict the
same way as we do he learns everything
about the halo rings and the flood when
we do the chief learning about cortana
and getting to know her is exactly what
we're doing and whether it was
intentional or not i think was a really
good way of getting the player to care
about its characters as for its
characters the game has a small cast of
important characters that are all fit
with different personalities captain
keys is a very confident and by-the-book
man but also willing to do what he can
to save others while the guilty spark is
a robotic ball that talks to himself
non-stop about anything that comes to
his mind it's these small details and
personalities that make them stand out
from each other and make them
recognizable amongst the crowd despite
its very simple story concept it's still
a fairly good narrative on its own the
game will give you objectives to do that
seem pointless but in the grand scheme
of things make sense mission 2 from
start to finish is all about rescuing
other marines stuck on the halo rink we
aren't furthering the plot we're not
making new discoveries we're just
rescuing soldiers given the context of
the previous mission where we see the
pillar of autumn crash land on an alien
planet it makes sense that the first
thing we do is regroup this string of
missions continues to lead us to other
places of importance like truth and
reconciliation and halo's control room
playing these missions really reinforced
the idea i talked about earlier hilo 1
gives the player bits of information
that would then be later revisited and
explored in later entries some could see
this as an optimist to look towards the
future of the series but some could see
this as an origin story with a lack of
substance personally i'm not really sure
what party i agree with knowing that
there's tons of sequels ahead of this
game i would agree with the former but
at the time it was never confirmed that
halo would get a sequel so you could
agree with the latter however what
really helped drive the narrative was
its presentation halo was filled with
gorgeous sky boxes as early as mission 2
and would introduce cutscenes with a
more cinematic approach opting for both
wide and close-up angles that could tell
the story all on its own whether it's
denoting the size of a structure or the
emotions of a character it was
wonderfully crafted and was able to
produce a feeling of engagement through
the camera work alone something many
games at the time couldn't do the
cinematic moment continues all the way
to its final missions where the chief is
taken back to the same locations that we
had already visited in the early
missions this decision to go back to
older areas definitely caused some
discrepancy amongst fans as it seems
like lazy game design but given the
game's short development cycle i'm not
sure how i feel about it regardless the
new missions do try to make combat and
navigation of the level fun despite it
being the same map and bungie just
barely managed to pull it off but being
able to explore other areas would have
been great like the finale where we run
through the halls of the pillar of
autumn again but most of the environment
is new to us making it not seem like the
same place we revisited in the intro
this all culminates in the ending scene
where we set the pillar of autumn to
blow and have to race down numerous
hallways and large open rooms to get to
safety i would say this was exhilarating
but it was quite the opposite while the
timer constantly ticking down does set
in a feeling of worry and nervousness
not knowing if you'll be able to make it
out in time the constant obstacles
combined with the awful driving
mechanics of ce makes it infuriating
more than anything it feels like the
game is actively working against you
rather than with you halo ce was
undoubtedly revolutionary in its time
and even till today from its intelligent
ai that react accordingly to the given
situation to its balanced and expansive
weaponry it is and was great and while
there might be some disagreement on
whether or not the game is actually good
due to it being very old and clearly
outdated in terms of mechanics one thing
we can agree on is that it was setting
the groundwork for something far greater
[Music]
following the success of halo combat
evolved bungie would be hard at work on
its sequel halo 2. from the gecko they
planned on making the game in a new
engine which features improved visuals
physics implementation and more
importantly xbox live halo 2 would be
the first halo game to feature online
multiplayer a feature that would be a
staple within the franchise due to an
overwhelming amount of players within
the multiplayer and land scene of combat
evolved bungie decided to double down on
multiplayer and make it possible for
xbox live besides the visual and
multiplayer upgrades its gameplay and
story was massively overhauled and very
ambitious in fact it was
too ambitious thanks to halo's success
bungie became extremely optimistic about
the future of the series now that they
had a solid amount of support from both
fans and microsoft they wanted to
continue making the best halo games they
could because of this its level design
gameplay and story all had a colossal
amount of content but most of it had to
be cut due to hardware limitations at e3
2003 there was a gameplay demo that
showcased the metropolis level early in
the game and while it looked great the
graphical enhancements were too much for
the xbox to handle and would have to be
cut that's also why you may have noticed
that halo 2's ending felt rushed or
unfinished as the team had planned on
adding more missions but was later cut
and repurposed for the sequel even
content within the missions was cut as
the level quarantined zone was only 20
of what the devs had built this led to
bungie scaling back their content it's
easy to add new content when there isn't
enough but it's harder to take content
away especially if it affects the
foundation of the game so the team had a
useless engine that was too powerful for
the current generation of consoles
levels that were too big to be put into
the game a storyline that was two games
worth of content mechanics and ideas
that weren't even implemented yet and to
top it all off bungie had 10 months
the studio was in chaos
any project that was in halo 2 was
immediately cancelled and the team was
working overtime 14-hour days 7 days a
week until its release to make things
even easier people would just sleep at
the office so they could get right back
to work this 10 months caused mental and
physical pain for every employee
involved core director jason jones
involvement in the games diminished and
would eventually lead him to creating an
entirely new ip to prevent this from
happening companies nowadays would delay
an upcoming project in favor of the
employees while being in the game's
reception but for bungie that wasn't an
option halo 2 was set to launch in
november 2004 and microsoft had already
planned to release the xbox 360 in 2005
meaning the upcoming christmas would be
the last christmas for the original xbox
which also meant that it was bungie's
last chance if they couldn't get the
game out in time there wouldn't be
another halo despite all these hurdles
however they made it not only did bungie
ship the game on time they discovered
something they never thought was
possible 2.4 million copies of halo 2
were purchased the day of its release it
this not only outpaced the original
making it the fastest selling halo game
but the fastest selling entertainment
product ever made to say halo 2 sold
well is an understatement it's to this
day the best-selling game on the
original xbox it was the most played
game of xbox live back then the fifth
most sold game in the united states and
with double halo 1 sales reaching over 8
million the game was an overnight
success but even though bungie would
celebrate it wasn't over yet the
community reception and critics still
needed to be pleased with the product
and if those numbers are any indication
the game was great it never managed to
surpass its predecessor's 97 metacritic
score but it's 95 is nothing to laugh at
fans of all kinds were pleased for the
most part for the first time ever you
could witness and experience the world
of the covenant through the eyes of the
arbiter head writer joseph staton wanted
to explore another side of halo we
haven't seen yet which led to the
creation of the arbiter despite massive
positivity over the decision some were
not happy as they felt it took away from
the master chief but this led to another
criticism which was the ending the
ending to some players felt rushed and
not complete because it was as we said
these cup missions would be used in halo
3 but that still didn't take away the
fact that at the time players weren't
left but much by the end of the game
halo 2 had introduced three new species
of covenant new storylines the reveal of
the gravemind and the entire reason the
covenant went to war for it all to be
left at a cliffhanger halo 2 starts with
a cinematic of the covenant council
where they discuss the aftermath of what
occurred in combat evolved the cinematic
opening is conveying to the player that
the covenant is going to be playing a
much larger role in this game than ever
before whereas the covenant before just
seemed like an army of aliens hell-bent
on destroying the human race this change
allowed the player to see them from a
different side we also got to see new
species being added like the prophets
and the brutes the prophets talked about
something called the great journey and
are discussing the failures of a
specific elite afterwards the focus is
back on master chief and his new
upgraded armor but as we continue into
the next mission the cutscenes start to
coil together from the master chief to
this elite and then back to him this is
the game slowly implying that this elite
is going to be very important for the
game going forward everything eventually
goes normal throughout the game as we
play as chief until mission 6 when we
revisit this elite that we now know as
the arbiter the game receives some minor
criticism over the arbiter but it wasn't
just because he took the spotlight away
from master chief some just didn't like
him which i find to be utterly bizarre
because of the arbiter we've been able
to see the world of the covenant through
his eyes it feels much more tacked on if
every few missions we would just peer
back to the console and its other
members expressing their disdain for the
master chief so by adding the arbiter we
not only get an origin story of a
specific soldier within the ranks but
can naturally see the state of the
covenant as we continue through the game
that's why the story of the great
journey was put into halo 2 as it's
displaying the inevitable downfall of
the covenant through the eyes of one of
its own we learn way more about the
great journey in the sequel but the game
is slowly dropping hints as to what's
truly going on as arbiter's first
mission is to eliminate an elite that
claims that the great journey is a lie
the idea of questioning the prophet's
true intention is made much clearer when
the brutes overtake the elites as the
main guards the elites are seen to be
the most trusted and respected units in
the covenant and for them to lose their
place in the high council is a
tremendous blow to the species thanks to
these drastic decisions by the prophets
it leads more elites to further question
their loyalty to the great journey and
the covenant this type of storytelling
can only be achieved through the eyes of
one of its soldiers it wouldn't have the
same emotional impact if we had just
seen it in a random cutscene bungie
wasn't just done at the covenant as they
still wanted the sequel to visit new
places levels outskirts and metropolis
take place on earth which is the first
time that the games have shown the
covenant attacking the unsc on their own
turf after weakening the covenant
cruiser during these missions the master
chief chases them through a slipspace
portal and arrives at a new halo ring
installation 0-5 each of these areas
have their own infrastructure and design
that set them apart from the other level
so it's easy to tell each other apart
halo 2's second half is a wonderful part
of the game as the arbiter and company
are busy doing work for the prophets
while also teetering the lines of
loyalty and betrayal meanwhile the unsc
are busy looking for the profit of
regret in hopes of figuring out their
fascination with these halo rings all of
this comes to a halt just like in halo 1
when the flood is reintroduced while the
flood functions the same as before just
killing whatever is in them what's more
important is when the arbiter and chief
meet with the grave mind this giant
omniscient creature is capable of
controlling all the flood the gravemind
is not only all-knowing but is very
manipulative while the master chief is
forced under high charity and takes the
opportunity to kill the prophets the
arbiter after being recently betrayed by
the brutes and the prophets set out to
stop tartarus and his brutes from
activating the halo ring arbiter meets
up with tartarus where we see our
favorite monitor again an attempt to
convince tartarus by using guilty spark
to prove that the prophets lied about
the halo rings you can tell that
tartarus definitely considers the
possibility but ultimately refuses which
show that his loyalty to the prophets
overpowers his common sense tartarus is
eventually stopped and after this
incredibly bad running animation arbiter
and company stopped the ring from
blowing up life in the galaxy once again
during all of this chief is still on
high charity with cortana who is also on
board taking control of their network
chief barely manages to make it to the
forerunner ship that the prophet was on
and is teleported near earth this is
what people meant by when they were
saying that the cliffhanger was not well
received as the game leaves the player
hanging at such a weird point in the
story and this even happens in the very
last cutscene as the great mind is seen
talking with cortana who is still on the
ship nothing here feels resolved there's
nothing wrong with a cliffhanger ending
but when the story seems to wrap up
nothing it feels like a waste of time
cortana is being questioned by the grave
mind the master chief is on a forerunner
ship with the prophet of truth many of
the covenant have decided to disband
from the covenant as they feel they've
been betrayed by the prophets and then
there's this entire unclear story with
the brutes nothing feels complete the
only thing that was completed was
stopping the halo ring from firing but
that added nothing halo 1 had the same
plot at the end of the game but the ring
was destroyed this one is still here
just like with halo 1 given the context
of the games it's fine as there's a
sequel that will tie everything together
but at the time no one knew if halo was
going to continue so it feels like a
slap in the face to them i said earlier
that the game had introduced massive
changes to its story but what also
changed was its gameplay halo 2's combat
is almost night and day compared to its
original the sequel added quality of
life features to make combat feel fresh
and exciting combined with the new enemy
types and weapons this combat is
enjoyable almost up until the very end
there were remakes of previous weapons
like the brute plasma pistol or
completely new weapons like the beam
shot sniper or coveted carbine halo
always had great combat thanks to its
responsive ai and balance of weapons
halo 2 is no exception all weapons
regardless of ammo count or damage were
exceptional and new additions were a
welcome sight within its gameplay the
team over a bungie would add numerous
quality of life changes like being able
to use energy swords but more
importantly the ability to do wheeled
weapons of the roughly 16 weapons and
halo 2's arsenal 6 can be dual-wielded
with any combination allowing you to
fully prepare for a situation or just
wanting to do extra damage on top of
this covenant vehicles now had speed
boost to make them faster and vehicles
could be hijacked if nearby while the
covenant vehicles were great the unsc
warthog and scorpion felt slower but
heavier making you feel the weight of
the vehicles you're driving due to this
the warthog handles incredibly well and
way better than the ce counterpart and
the scorpion is much more accurate and
does not require that tedious long
reload in between shots this combat
change overall made the game accessible
to a much larger market especially with
the removal of health pickups hilo's
health system of having a separate
health and shield bar with med kits was
removed and replaced with just a shield
bar in the bottom left your health when
the shields went out was uncertain
giving a bit of tension in fights but it
seemed to make the master chief weaker
making the combat tougher this was made
much more apparent with the flood and
the brutes the flood continues to be
very annoying creatures but thankfully
there isn't an hour-long mission filled
with them like the library the flood was
much better utilized in this game as
opposed to ce as now dead corpses could
be revived by the smaller flood forms
and they weren't ambushing you in waves
95 of the time due to your low shield
and overall health though a swing from a
flood without a shield is a death
sentence and the brutes are by far the
worst defender of this if a brood is low
on health they will rage and charge at
the player either knocking them into a
corner or juggling them until they die
the brutes do not comply with halo's
weapon balance it's not about choosing
the weapons you want but the weapons you
need i wouldn't have been able to make
it through many of these levels without
the energy sword and even then i was
still very close to my death despite
having less health when in rage mode
their damage resistance is astronomical
as for their weapons the brute shot when
put in the hands of a brute is somehow
the deadliest and most accurate weapon
in the whole game the roots also don't
have any sort of hit registration so
there's no way to tell how much damage
you're doing or if you're doing any
damage at all grunts will knock their
head back when damage is taken and
elites will scream when their shields
are broken but the brutes do absolutely
nothing just get on all fours and charge
you halo 2 also introduced three boss
fights and they're all laughably bad i
was going to count the scarab fight but
seeing as that's 95 scripted and you
really don't even destroy it i didn't
bother adding it to the list the first
one i can forgive though as the elite
heretic is really just a re-skinned
elite with slightly higher health and
seeing as we've killed hundreds of them
before this really didn't feel any
different but the prophet and tartarus
are just awful upon entering this
4runner structure as the chief we come
face to face with the prophet of regret
he used a laser beam that produces
incredible damage meaning you need to
shoot from cover so i did round after
round was put into him only being
separated by the numerous energy sword
wielding honor guards that were easily
defeated due to the dual-wield mechanics
the prophet is like the brutes where he
has no hit registration so it's hard to
tell if you're actually doing damage
until you walk up to him and realize you
have to kill him by punching him i would
have rather just had a cutscene instead
of this interaction and it was actually
hilarious how bad this looked all that
trouble just to be finished off by a
couple punches and tartarus was just as
bad he's the only brute with a shield
but bungie couldn't even get that right
as his shield never changes color gets
bigger or literally does anything to
imply the damage is being done i
actually thought i needed to activate a
button or use a specific weapon but no
he's taking damage you just can't see it
and if you thought the hunters were fun
to tango with try fighting tartarus as
long as you move in a circle he's never
gonna hit you i can't tell if bungie
added these allies to help you fight him
so that they could give tartarus other
things to swing at or they discovered
this awful behavior in development and
couldn't figure out a way to fix it
regardless tartarus is an awful boss and
an even worse final boss while bungie is
owen 3 on boss fights that's not to say
the rest of the game was bad in fact
it's far from it halo 2 was a wonderful
game that was made to do its job improve
the sequel and be used as a conduit for
combat evolves cut content and it did
exactly that it added numerous gameplay
changes that would make things more
accessible to a wider audience but keep
the integrity of halo's difficulty it
also continued to reinforce those exact
qualities that made halo's combat fun in
the first place balanced weaponry and
intelligent ai
at least for the most part with the
overwhelming amount of sales and the
enormous amount of cut content bungie
knew that a sequel was inevitable
[Music]
halo 3 was a new creation with a new
console due to the past game's awful
development conditions the team refused
to let something like this happen again
and made sure to negotiate and plan
ahead bungie and even many fans figured
a sequel was in order the team had
constantly expressed their distaste with
halo 2's final decisions and attempted
to write their wrongs with halo 3. just
as halo 2 was filled with cut halo 1
content halo 3 was the leftover
ambitious decisions that bungie wouldn't
have time to implement one of these
decisions was its graphical enhancements
with a new engine and also a new xbox
boundaries could be pushed further than
ever before allowing for what they truly
wanted halo to look like bungie would
also add numerous quality of life
changes and improvements to its ai but
more on that later minus the occasional
update on bungie's website this game's
development is quite unknown as we don't
really know what steps they took to make
it however we do know the outcome and
that outcome was incredible i talked
about halo 2's successful launch but
it's nothing compared to halo 3. halo 3
would be the second time a sequel would
outsell the previous title when halo 3
released in 2007 within 12 days it had
reached 3 million copies and in 2 months
it would sell 5 million but it didn't
stop there due to an overwhelming amount
of players that played multiplayer and
the teases of its forge mode halo 3
would sell over 15 million copies in 5
years making it the most sold halo game
and the best-selling game of 2007. this
was the peak of halo and it's fitting as
the game would be the last halo made by
bungie ending the trilogy and the series
on high note bungie wanted to distance
themselves from microsoft and halo so
they would terminate their contract
together after they finished halo 3.
however that part isn't entirely true
for obvious reasons but i will get to
that soon after its initial launch
community reception was overwhelmingly
positive multiplayer was considered
perfect with the best lineup of maps in
the entire series and forge mode was a
game changer but its campaign had
suffered a bit many complaints over its
short length were echoed across the
forums and some were very critical of
specific levels like its eighth mission
which of course featured the flood
another major complaint was its ai
functionality as while the enemy ai was
better than ever before your allies were
not i have the same exact feeling about
this that i did with the arbiter i am
completely dumbfounded by this the
allies have never been great they
they're sometimes incredibly accurate
when shooting in a warthog but
progressing the story is done by you not
your teammates as for the covenant i'd
argue halo 3's ai seems less intelligent
than the others and i think it's due to
more accessibility everything in halo
seemed to be added for the sake of
helping the player rather than hindering
them punching a mounted vehicle is much
faster making it an easy crutch
especially when using a plasma pistol
which can now stun vehicles if charged
numerous weapons like the assault rifle
and shotgun traded magazine size and
reload speed for more damage making the
former ultimately not matter weapons
would be placed in convenient spots
making certain levels not engaging in
the slightest and enemies would outright
ignore me and do absolutely nothing
there was also new equipment like bubble
shields regenerators and flares that
could be used by both the brute and the
master chief but felt strong in your
hands and weak in theirs like this
energy drain that would completely
eliminate any form of tension that i had
against this brute chieftain and of
course this was conveniently placed
right before the elevator but by far the
worst defender once again is the brutes
i'm going to sound insatiable given what
i said about them in halo 2 but let me
explain the roots are the main focus of
this game thanks to halo 2's story and
the brutes were massively nerfed in halo
3. roots seem to fill the same role as
the elites throughout the series in halo
2 the brutes were a step above elites
they were meant to be tough and powerful
but due to their enormous health and
damage resistance coupled with a lack of
hit registration they're more annoying
rather than challenging halo 3 would
change this by adding armor to the
brutes that would act as a shield and
would slowly strip away the more help
they lost but seeing as they were
replacing the elites within halo's
combat they became the elites they're
incredibly easy to take on in this game
with their infamous charge being
sometimes useless and bruce don't dodge
from grenades the same as elites do but
rather just sit still and cover their
face hoping the grenade literally in
front of them won't kill them they did
eventually add jetpacks to the brutes
allowing them to surround you if you
aren't careful but they don't fire when
jetpacking making them just another
brute with no cover to hide behind and
more of a hitbox to aim at furthermore
the brute weapons are downright powerful
unsc firearms helped when taking away
health while the covenant weapons
excelled against shields the brute
weapons excel against both no amount of
armor shields or health would matter as
the spiker mauler broodshot and gravity
hammer ignored any resistances they may
have had to add even more to this the
broodshot now had six rounds instead of
four and is more common thanks to the
abundance of brutes within the game and
the spiker and mauler can be
dual-wielded allowing for double the
firepower it makes the brute weapons
easily the best in the game for almost
any situation despite the large amount
of criticism that i've just given though
i love halo 3's combat in fact i think
it's my favorite in the entire trilogy
i've always come back to this game if i
want to have a fun time and ultimately
that's what's most important you could
add dozens of changes to your game but
if it's not fun then you've already
failed and halo 3 is far from that
simultaneously adding new changes to the
game but also managing to keep it fun
halo 3's possible additions were
astronomical and due to bungie having
more time and more opportunities with
the xbox 360 they were going to add it
all bungie wanted to expand on the brew
culture now they've had a full game
about them so they took the opportunity
to add numerous additions to their
arsenal the brutes come equipped with
all different sorts of covenant and
brute weapons making the firefights
different as while two brutes may look
the same their weapons may not be the
same the brutes also have a sort of pack
mentality as it's quite rare to find
only a few of them together and even if
that's the case they're either extremely
strong or surrounded by other covenant
members whereas halo 1 was less combat
per area but had a lot of familiar areas
and halo 2 was less areas but more
combat within them halo 3 is the perfect
mix of both bungie seemed to nail the
balance of map layout and enemy quantity
making it long enough to be enjoyable
but not overstay its welcome you will
rarely ever find yourself defending an
objective for a long period of time and
while there are some places notably
towards the end where you're fighting
brutes within the same area its variety
in enemy placement and layout make it
seem like a new experience bungie really
wanted to hone in on its combat from all
forms as this game has the most vehicles
and weapons in the series so far all the
weapons from halo 2 have returned along
with the assault rifle which was not
present in the previous game the magnum
is now a combination of halo 1 and 2s
reverting the original look but keeping
its inability to aim down sight the
needler also got its dual-wield
capability removed possibly due to its
imbalance in multiplayer but it's more
accurate and damaging than its previous
iterations halo 3 would also continue
the trend of adding new ways to fight in
combat the spartan laser was introduced
later towards mission 7 and the biggest
change was its addition of heavy weapons
throughout the game there are turrets
with unlimited ammo and are great for
defending a position by ripping them off
you can take these weapons to the enemy
at the loss of its unlimited ammo it
made these powerful weapons still seem
like wants rather than needs you didn't
need to use these weapon to survive but
you could if you wanted to halo 3 also
surprised me by improving on the flood
and boss fights which were lacking in
the previous games the flood is much
easier to take on in this game and
doesn't overstay its welcome within
certain missions the game introduces the
flood in mission 6 with a covenant
carrier being flown in by the flood this
leads to the arbiter-in-chief pushing
their way through the base so they can
be evacuated later instead of a covenant
cruiser high charity arrives the same
flood-infested city from halo 2 and
seeing as we've been chasing cortana
this whole game this is the perfect time
to take her back the beginning of the
mission is great as you're slowly making
your way through the area but then it
just keeps going and going for quite a
long time the flood also bugged out a
lot here as half the enemies in some
sections barely acknowledge my presence
and it's also the best example of weapon
convenience throughout this level you'll
find dozens of energy swords you fought
the flood in this exact same spot in
halo 2 and there was nowhere near this
many last time there was never a time i
didn't have one the energy sword can
also kill any flood in one to maybe two
swings making this ridiculously boring
also and i'll get to the story
significance of this later but this is
where both the cortana and gravemind
will talk to you whenever they talk this
is when you're forced to walk at an
extremely slow speed and while the
missions in the beginning aren't too bad
it becomes a big deal way later when
it's just after every single engagement
as for its boss fights halo 3 doesn't
have the most in terms of variety but it
does still have some worthy boss fights
there are four within this game three of
them being scarab sequences and the last
being the guilty spark i'll never forget
the first time i fought the scarab it
was exhilarating and tough but i didn't
really feel that anymore it probably was
down to the fact that i already knew its
weakness and thus finished the fight in
less than two minutes but i do remember
the fun i had the first time around the
scarab has two main sources of damage
which is its head and its body but you
could also count the legs assuming you
aren't paying attention both of these
sources of damage are busy attacking the
other enemies so it's rare that the
scarab will actually attack you making
the first fight easy but this is a very
tough enemy so if the game can help in
any way at least for the first time
around i think that will improve the
overall enjoyability of the game the
second scarified attempts to add more
enemies and bump up the difficulty a bit
which it does but only for so long as
the game gives you numerous allies to
act as cannon fodder and a tank to tank
out the legs i feel like the intention
was to slowly raise the difficulty by
changing the environment and enemies
within the area but i never felt that
with this fight it just seemed that the
difficulty got easier since i knew how
to defeat the scarabs and they gave me a
tank to stop it the very last scarified
is much tougher as it adds two scarabs a
severe lack of cover other additional
enemies that attack you and you aren't
given some massive tank just a mongoose
so to effectively defeat them you need
to grab one of the other vehicles the
covenant drops and do it yourself having
both of their beams cross and kill you
is extremely annoying and the game does
refuse to provide a checkpoint after one
is dead making this tougher and while it
was frustrating it felt like an actual
boss fight the enemies on the scarabs
are either equal to the fuel rod cannon
or using the plasma turrets so you not
only have to worry about the scarabs
from both far and close range you also
have to worry about the enemies shooting
you on top of it to make it even worse
you have way less allies this time
around than even if you actually did it
never felt as if they were being
targeted however this game's bosses end
on such a sour note despite the praise
it seems to get guilty sparks fight is
bad just like the other fights you don't
know this is coming and it just sort of
happens so there's no way to prepare
ahead of time given that the entire
level so far has been flood obviously
i'm gonna run the shotgun an energy
sword however this loadout is worthless
the guilty spark will push you away if
you get too close making this loadout
incapable of damaging him but sergeant
johnson with his last breath will shoot
him it seems like the game is allowing
you to push forward and go on the attack
but it's actually so the player can grab
the spartan laser as a few shots is all
that's needed to kill him he also never
moved from the same position so it's
impossible to miss him this is arguably
the worst example of weapon convenience
as the one weapon that can greatly
damage the guilty spark happens to be
the one weapon johnson brought with him
to defeat the flood i don't ever recall
a spartan laser being effective against
waves of flood it's also 100 intended
for you to grab this weapon because of
this i just wish that you could use the
loadout you came in with or at the very
least if they want to use the spartan
laser have the chief get shot falling
off the ledge with enough time to save
himself but not the weapons he came in
with then give johnson his last shot as
he instructs the chief to take his
weapon and we defeat the guilty spark
that way it makes the weapon convenience
not matter as it's literally the only
weapon available rather than being the
only one that can damage him it's a sad
excuse for a boss fight and once again
another awful way to end the game and
the entire series thankfully this time
the boss fight wasn't the absolute last
thing we do in the game as there is
another race sequence reminiscent of
halo 1's last level but we should
probably discuss how everything got to
this point first halo 3's campaign sort
of leaves off where halo 2s left off
except we go from the chief inside of a
forerunner ship with the prophet of
truth to flying down through space into
earth how we got to this point is not
explained to the player and only
mentioned in a comic called halo
uprising this will be one of the many
times in the series where lore and plot
points aren't filled in for the sake of
the comics or books to cover regardless
in this instance it's not of a huge deal
so i tend to look past it after a short
bit of conversation the master chief
wakes up like nothing had happened and
is ready to fight the covenant halo 3
does a great job at remembering its past
lore as while sergeant johnson sees the
arbiter as a friend the master chief
sees him as an enemy since he's unaware
of the alliance that occurred throughout
the end of the game they don't get off
on the right foot but as the game goes
on they will solidify their friendship
as the arbiter refers to master chief as
the demon then simply as spartan and
master chief after the ending jump
sequence will look back at him to make
sure he survived at the beginning of the
game they were simply enemies in an
unstable alliance but they would
eventually become actual friends as the
story continued the master chief also
has no clue what happened to the halo
ring and seeing as miranda was there she
was able to bring him up to speed she
also mentions that it's weird how all
the covenant are in east africa instead
of all over the planet which is then
revealed in a later mission that the
covenant found a portal that supposedly
leads right to the ark which can fire
all the halo rings it's also shown
earlier on that cortana is leaking into
master chief's mind they never explain
this but i can only assume that it's the
gravemind's doing but he also does the
same thing and that's never explained
either around mission 4 is where you'll
notice that the game is really pushing
the boundaries of its cinematography
halo 1 and 2 had some incredible camera
angles that were a lot better than a
simple back and forth of dialogue that
other games would do it's like watching
a movie but also being able to play it
as well and halo 3 is no exception in
fact it seemed bungie leaned heavily
into this style as the showcase of the
covenant and unsc troops going to the
portal is incredibly gorgeous this is
also where the flood is introduced and
the chief ends up finding a message of
cortana everyone evacuates the city and
the covenant glass the entire area this
is a really important part of the game
as it clearly shows the covenant will do
anything necessary even if it means
killing their allies to stop the flood
lord hood even brings this up to us as
him and the shipmaster have a heated
argument about this exact decision after
the dispute they view the message from
cortana where she tells everyone that
there's a way for the flood to die
without actually activating the halo
rings but we need to get to the ark upon
making it to the arc we find the
cartographer and are able to determine
truth's exact location but he's
activated a barrier around the ark's
core so we have to split into three
teams to take him down during this
assault johnson's team is overrun by the
brutes and ends up getting captured by
the prophet as a human can only activate
the ark since it has to do with the
mantle of responsibility which at the
time we don't even know what that is yet
seeing as we've had numerous covenant
forces defending the citadel we're
running out of time as truth is about to
activate the halo rings but miranda
breaks through the glass and halts him
it seemed that the plan was to get
sergeant johnson out of there which then
turned into her killing herself and
sergeant johnson since no human would be
able to activate the ring so she
single-handedly with no other soldiers
thought it was a smart idea to attack
the leader of the covenant who no doubt
had guards with him but she's not just a
random human she's a literal commander
of the unsc i understand that with the
circumstances at play drastic things
need to be done i just feel like there
wasn't a whole lot of thought put into
her plan and her death just feels
completely wasted right after this comes
the most bizarre twist the series has
offered with a grave mind wants to forge
an alliance to stop truth the two
reluctantly agree and manage to stop the
ark from firing and defeat the prophet
however i said in halo 2 that the grave
mind is a master manipulator and i feel
like a lot of people saw this coming as
now the flood is attacking the
arbiter-in-chief since they're now saved
from extinction the two of them run away
from the control room and end up
discovering that the ark ended up making
a new halo ring and replacement for the
one destroyed back in halo 1. this
starts a new plan where it's to activate
this halo's current ring which will
destroy the flood within the vicinity
and since the ark is light years away
from earth the humans and covenant
should be spared from this explosion
even guilty spark is in agreement with
this plan so while he prepares the ring
master chief needs to find cortana not
only to save her but also because she
still has the index from halo one a
small detail that was honestly my
favorite part about the game even after
six years of development and adding and
removing new things for two whole games
bungie never forgot about the small
details and that's extremely commendable
this index can light the ring which was
the plan except when we take it to the
control room guilty spark says it will
be fired in a few days but johnson
refuses to accept that and launches it
anyway if we fire the ring too early it
will destroy the ark and the new
installation which causes guilty spark
to get aggravated and attack us despite
his cheery tone throughout the game he's
always had a grudge for us countless
times we've ruined his plan he was made
to do so it was inevitable that he'd get
pushed over the edge at some point
johnson's death wasn't as bad as miranda
seeing as no one really saw it coming
and wasn't a complete suicide mission
the master chief has to put down the
monitor and then race to a nearby ship
so they can leave before they get
consumed in the blast this ending chase
is by far the coolest way to end a game
and a series this was definitely an
homage to halo 1's last level which had
a similar way of ending the game except
this mission has no timer and the
control of the warthog feels much better
even though there isn't any urgency
since there's no timer the tiles will
start to crumble and eventually force
you to die and reset if you're too slow
the area is also much more open than
before so it's not constant twisting and
turning to get around every small
obstacle this whole sequence is
accompanied by the wonderful soundtrack
and is always a wonderful mission to
play from my very first time a decade
ago to today i still love this mission
after you make it to the end you go down
the ramp as fast as possible and launch
into the back of the ship and take off
with hopefully enough time to survive
the blast the ring blows up and the ark
installation and the flood are
presumably destroyed afterwards we see a
memorial to the fallen soldiers and a
truce made by both the covenant and the
unsc we see a 117 engraved on the ship
implying that master chief died in the
explosion but as we discovered that's
untrue both the arbiter and chief are
unaware that the others survive but go
on with their lies regardless arbiter
returns to his homeworld as the new
shipmaster and the face of the elite and
the master chief stays in cryo with
cortana waiting for someone to find them
thus ending halo 3 the covenant human
war and the trilogy
i would say that this is a fitting end
to the series some things are left
unexplained but it wraps up fairly well
halo 3 is probably the best game in the
entire trilogy as it achieved an almost
perfect balance in combat and was able
to tell a story bungie originally wanted
to make and they did so effectively as
for the entire trilogy the first three
halo games will always be remembered for
years as one of the best series in
gaming history halo 1 set the groundwork
halo 2 added numerous quality of life
changes that would then be carried into
halo 3 which then finished the story and
created a perfect synergy between its
combat and map layout these three games
are responsible for many fans happiest
memories and moments but also
responsible for putting microsoft and
its xbox on the map in the gaming
marketplace whether it was its gripping
campaign or its competitive multiplayer
everyone loved halo it would push new
boundaries as one of the best fps games
on consoles and one of the most
anticipated games of the sixth and
seventh generation of consoles it was
because of that popularity though that
microsoft would refuse to let halo die
this early
after halo 3 was developed bungie
created two internal teams and after
some discussion and some cancelled
projects the team ultimately created two
new games that i have to call the halo
spin-offs odst in reach are seen as
departures from the original series odst
was the first game to not feature any
spartans and reach would be the first
game where you play as a spartan that
isn't the master chief these two games
are still to the state of the only games
than the fps genre to not feature the
master chief and not take a place
immediately after the next game both of
these games fit in different spots and
the timeline and bungie did this so they
could tell more stories so far in the
series we've seen things from the master
chief in the arbiter's perspective but
both these games allow us to delve into
the other sides of the war whether it's
the aftermath of places we've already
visited or completely new place entirely
and since we're playing as someone else
that means the story will change
anything involving the master chief is
followed by some large stunt or action
scene like delivering the bomb to the
covenant or crashing into the ground at
insane speeds but these people aren't
spartan 117 the master chief is supposed
to be an anomaly the finest super
soldier ever made which means that these
people are both not as strong and much
more fragile this current section is
about these two games the games that
would be bungie's last creations and the
games that were bridges between both
sagas of halo and the ones many remember
the most
[Music]
odst was a return to form for halo it
brought back that difficulty and
rewarding gameplay seen in combat
evolved but it wasn't because the ai was
changed our character had changed seeing
as the official name is halo 3 odst it's
not far off to assume that it was made
using the same engine assets and
software these decisions make it hard to
talk about its combat as its most basic
form because it's something we've
already discussed in the halo 3 chapter
you can immediately tell from playing
that something is off numerous weapons
in the game could tear through a brute's
armor and health in no time but in odst
this isn't the case it's hard to tell
whether it's the enemies that have
gotten stronger or we as the player have
gotten weaker due to us not being a
super soldier but it's very obvious in
the very first moments of the game this
is nothing like halo 3. one of these
changes is something you'll discover by
the end and it's that odst is really
short this campaign on normal clocked in
at around three to four hours there are
many variables that can change this
number like difficulty in the searching
of audio logs but assuming you're
playing through on a normal run of the
campaign you're not going to be playing
this game very long but this wasn't
something the team never expected in
fact it was decided during its early
stages of development that odst was
going to be a short campaign some
players at the time really didn't care
as many were just going to play halo 3's
multiplayer again or maybe take a crack
at odst's multiplayer since it'd be the
first game without spartans but odst
never had a multiplayer it added
something different odst in reach would
be the only two games for the
foreseeable future to add firefight a
horde based mode that was you and some
friends against waves of covenant it was
honestly some great fun for a time and
especially when adding friends to your
team or when you could change to
different maps but that only holds
people for so long odst's biggest
criticism was its length but not the
fact that it was short but it was short
with a 60 dollar price tag multiplayer
is the one game mode people will play
the most in any game if you give the
game mode numerous rewards and options
players could put hundreds of hours into
it which is why halo's multiplayer has
always been so fun there were tons of
different game modes to play in
customization that the player could work
towards but in odst they didn't have
that firefight's main rewards were its
character options and that you could
pick to play as anyone from the squad
but those were unlocked by completing
campaign missions so assuming you were
like most players and played the
campaign first you would have already
had everyone unlocked even though i
wouldn't be playing odst for a long time
during that time i did play i was
enthralled by it odst can be summarized
by the phrase here for a good time not a
long time while you may not be
physically playing the game long during
the time you do play it you'll be having
a great time with it odst takes place
during halo 2. in fact it's during one
of the missions in halo 2. in the
mission metropolis where the prophet of
regret withdrew from new mumbasa he
decided to teleport using a slipspace
portal but used it inside the city
causing a massive explosion the odsts
were tasked with landing on a ship and
then taking it over but their plans were
thwarted thanks to this event this
caused their paws to lose communication
and power and also push them off course
splitting the entire team up our goal at
the moment is to regroup with our squad
then find a way out of the city odst
wanted to paint a more noir-like image
to the game this is where the game is
always at night and is rather unsettling
to walk through the city just hours ago
was filled with people then became the
site of a war and then nothing it's
completely silent but the only sounds
being heard are police sirens
malfunctioning technology and its
soundtrack to make things worse we don't
even know if our squad had survived so
we could be the only person left in a
city filled with covenant it's truly an
unsettling experience and one that the
series hasn't done yet what really
helped set this up was its world this is
the first time halo has given an open
world style to its levels in the halo
games prior and even the ones released
after all the levels were fairly linear
and a completion of these levels would
take you to the next one immediately
odst doesn't do that because its
missions are flashbacks after getting
out of your pod you're tasked with
finding your squad by finding their
beacons on the newly made map of new
mombasa you'll then go to these areas
find the object of importance do a
flashback mission then shoot back to the
rookie and continue searching for more
clues to get there you'll have to walk
using your compass and your eyes to
guide you to the next sector of the city
it's crazy how just the simple
adjustment in tone and time can change
your entire outlook on something during
the flashback missions they felt like
normal halo combat going from one place
to another completing some objective and
killing it's on a covenant in your way
like normal but when i played as the
rookie i felt like new mombasa's only
hope that i truly was the very last
person alive so i tried my hardest to
avoid combat as i felt that i couldn't
take on larger squads due to being
severely outnumbered this was all pretty
much untrue as the rookie is just as
powerful as everyone else on the team
but that change in tone gave off that
vibe and it's always stuck with me
whenever i play it odst's also come
equipped with the visor mode which is to
assist the player in identifying enemies
and seeing into dark rooms i've never
known how to explain this properly but
because of visor mode the game's overall
color scheme changes to help the player
see but there's something beautiful
about remembering that this is on and
then turning it off to see what the
world truly looked like in darkness what
i think really ties this together has
always been its soundtrack martin
o'donnell and michael salvatore the ones
responsible for all the music in halo
thus far also returned for odst but
decided to completely change things
around adding more jazz to the
soundtrack rather than a large chorus
odst's music has always stuck out to
many players but i think a big reason
for that was its change in tone but also
due to the game's silence during
missions and the other halo games while
the music is present it's low enough to
be considered background music but not
loud enough to really tell that it's
there since you're more focused on the
combat in front of you but because new
mombasa is so quiet the music takes
center stage allowing its gorgeous
soundtrack to be heard all the time
odst's decision to change its tone was
not only reflected in its music and
atmosphere but also its story it's a
grim story filled with uncertainty as we
go from one place to the next finding
the remnants of our team hoping that by
the end of the flashback they aren't
dead realizing that it's night time is a
weird feeling knowing this entire time
you've been asleep people have been
dying and your whole team has been
stranded seeing as the rookie missed the
majority of the fighting and can't
really help anyone he takes it upon
himself to find the missing squad and
reconvene and figure out what to do the
squad members he's trying to find are
buck dutch romeo mickey and veronica all
of them are unique and create incredible
moments with each other showing the
relationship each of them have already
established some of the members notably
romeo and buck are always smart asses
ready to crack a joke in any moment i've
always felt that dutch and veronica are
more by the book soldiers but in the
sense that dutch is always combat ready
and willing to do the heavy lifting if
it means fighting the good fight and
when veronica's given objective she'll
do it no matter the cost between them
however it seems that veronica and buck
had a previous relationship and that
ties into buck's character who was upset
at how cold she was to him in the
beginning but is still willing to go
back into the covenant-infested city
just to find her the main story of odst
is about human beings not super soldiers
this isn't some action-packed adventure
with explosives and superhuman feats
it's about a story of human beings in a
tide of war unsure what to do mistakes
will be made and decisions don't make
sense as they're all human with no real
objective in mind as that vanished as
quickly as it arrived this decision
makes the story more grounded more
realistic and in some ways more
enjoyable as halo has never seen a story
like this before when the master chief
says he'll do something he does it but
these characters aren't him so at least
room for faults mistakes and constant
vulnerability going back to the story at
hand the rookie needs to find his squad
and we can piece together a fairly good
timeline of events thanks to the
timeframes mentioned in the beginning of
the missions upon landing buck went to
go and rescue veronica who was deep
behind covenant lions after battling
through waves of enemies he made it but
was too late that she was already gone
buck was about to be attacked by a new
covenant enemy called an engineer until
romeo arrives and saves him for the next
three hours buck and romeo would search
for the remainder of the squad in hopes
of getting everyone out safe eventually
they would come in contact with mickey
and dutch who were told to meet at the
new mombasa police headquarters except
when they arrive dutch and mickey are
shot down by a group of banshees and
need to be rescued going back in time
both mickey and dutch were initially
split dutch landing near the nature
reserve and mickey near kazingle
boulevard before eventually meeting up
and working with the police to blow up
the oni alpha site building they then
get on a pelican which is how they made
it to the headquarters buck and romeo
join the team and help defend them until
a brew chieftain arrives and almost
kills romeo before being tackled by the
rest of the team and then make it to
kikowani station in hopes of finding
some way to leave the city and decide to
take a phantom as the train is
decommissioned the four work together to
escape new mombasa before buck orders
them to turn around so they can rescue
veronica all of this happens in five
hours and given the fact that the rookie
didn't wake up for six after the initial
drop he was asleep for all of this
throughout this you'll notice that the
game is taking a different approach to
its cutscenes but still presenting an
expert level of cinematography the
reason for halo success in this
department is the game's ability to tell
a story without using words the camera
angles are able to show emotions without
ever telling us and seeing as we now
have a completely silent protagonist
that is sort of a detective throughout
the game the camera angles and
presentation have changed since
everything in the flashbacks has already
happened we see the aftermath of
everything that's occurred the only
building we see being blown up is still
on fire when we arrive it tells a story
of loss and beauty that you can't find
in other halo games the loss of the
lives that died there and the
intelligence that was stored within its
walls but there's also beauty in its
destruction as the embers and flames
engulfing the building coincide with the
destruction around it painting the sky
with this orange smoke-filled color it's
a genuine work of art and this continues
to be utilized even in its final moments
as we finish the flashback we hear
veronica and now can track her location
we find her and work with her to finish
her real mission which is to collect the
superintendent's data virgil is the
superintendent who runs dumbass and his
data is very critical according to her
except the engineer consumed his data
which may be a problem except these
engineers are actually hive minds of
covenant data the data on this engineer
could help win the war so it's critical
that we escort this thing to safety
which we do with the help of buck who
comes to assist us we drive down this
long highway in new mombasa in hopes of
making it to the rest of the gang most
of the highway is filled with enemies so
it's hard to pay attention to the
surrounding area when you're being
distracted which is specifically why the
game will put the carrier within your
field of view and when no combat has
started so you have no choice but to
stare at it the carrier creates this
looming presence you've seen what
they're capable of doing and you know
what's coming next you're just hoping
that it doesn't happen this time will
your suspicions come true as the
covenant continues to glass yet another
city on earth plans need to be changed
and fast as the covenant are not going
to wait for us to leave so the rest of
the squad meets with the others and they
hold out against waves of covenant that
feel like an eternity our phantom
arrives and the crew manages to get to
both the engineer and everyone out of
the city making for a happy ending if
you call the destruction of an entire
city happy halo odst is a somber story
not one of heroic achievement but one of
darkness and destruction many people see
video games as a form of art but odst
takes that to the next level by
presenting a world and atmosphere not
explored yet and is truly managed to
create a bleak world filled with silence
and abandoned architecture i just wish
more people were able to appreciate it
as opposed to odst which was meant to be
a short but enjoyable experience halo
reach was not it was all about going big
or going home halo reach is also
responsible for changing how we play
halo as this was the very first time we
see spartans on screen that weren't the
master chief in fact we got six
different spartans who are all
completely unique to one another reach
was also the first game to allow player
customization to our main character
seeing as most of mobile 6 is a mystery
bungie took it upon themselves to add
customization to our protagonist any
armor you wear for multiplayer is
immediately transferred to the character
in the campaign mobile 6 was truly a
character you could put yourself in the
shoes of while playing because he was
you buried wasn't stopping there we were
given a new planet to explore new
covenant species new weapons spartan
abilities assassinations space combat
night visions marine fire teams and
numerous other changes reach was so
different from the other entries that
you would think it'd be negatively
viewed amongst fans but you'd be wrong
reach received critical acclaim upon
release and was an overnight success
generating 200 million dollars in total
revenue within 24 hours minus the return
of firefight and an incredible
multiplayer that kept people playing for
years what also captivated players was
its campaign after starting at
single-player reach wastes no time
introducing its lovable cast each one of
them is unique in looks personality and
expertise we also get to see what almost
everyone looks like under their helmets
making the player feel more personally
connected to them noble team is the
perfect example of what a team should be
like each of them have their own set of
skills and when one is missing you can
see how difficult things can get carter
is the team leader he has the combat
knowledge and skill to stay alive in any
firefight but is common collected enough
to relay new orders on the fly when
needed during an early mission a group
of zealot elites ambush the group and
while three large zealots with energy
swords will scare just about anyone
carter stays calm and gives orders on
how to proceed and everyone listens they
trust carter's decisions and only rarely
did anyone question his orders even when
that did happen he was able to create
and execute a thorough plan to complete
that objective as for the rest cat fits
the role of a hacker constantly jamming
and hacking into covenant systems
throughout the game june is a sniper
emilia's close quarters george is a
heavy gunner and noble 6 is the
all-around expert each of them are
different and have different skill sets
none of them can carry weapons like
george does and no one is even close to
being as good of a leader as carter what
really brings these characters to life
is their personalities george seems like
an angry guy on the outside but cares
deeply for others as he tries to calm a
civilian down that they just rescued an
emile shows that he doesn't fear the
thought of death he honors those who
want to go out on their own terms and is
not the type of person to argue about it
like i said halo reaches the blueprint
for how a team should function even if
it makes sense to have everyone on the
team be the same to maximize the success
of a mission when you give the
characters faults it makes them feel
more human and ultimately makes for a
better story and that story is one of
grief and irony halo reach's story is
unfair it's not about happy endings this
is apparent before even starting the
game halo reaches a prequel to the
original trilogy and according to buck
in odst the entire planet of reach was
glass just like new mombasa so somehow
this planet went from being full of life
to being completely abandoned meaning
something had happened and it all
unfolds throughout the game the first
mission does an excellent job of keeping
things consistent with the lore while
also dropping hints on reach's
inevitable downfall as stated earlier we
get introduced to our cast of characters
while also learning about our own
character noble 6 is not only just the
all-around expert in terms of combat
he's also a lone wolf most of his file
is classified but carter went through
the trouble of reading it and while he
doesn't exactly tell us what happened it
seems that noble 6 would go out on his
own and complete missions without the
team's help making him the lone wolf
during this it's also where we see a
wide shot of a mountain range on reach
and our cracked helmet on the ground
there isn't enough evidence to make a
solid conclusion on why her helmet is
there but that doesn't look like a good
sign as we start the first mission
carter briefs the team on the objective
and that's to investigate a downed relay
outpost to hopefully find the people
responsible and to get it back online
george asks why the rebels would want to
cut communications with the planet this
is extremely important as the usual
go-to answer for this question is that
the covenant are attacking but reach
hasn't seen any covenant activity yet so
they just believe that it's some rebels
who did it this was a welcome change to
halo as it's always been the covenant
but since this is a prequel this is a
nice way to introduce them as this
looming threat that you know will arrive
on reach but you just don't know when as
noble team approaches a nearby structure
they open the door and find farmers who
inform them that they're hiding as they
heard shooting last night and that
something in the fields killed the
farmer's son we push further into the
settlement and find the missing troopers
we were searching for but also
discovered that what attacked them was
the covenant reach tried to set the
scene of the game by not immediately
having fire fights with the covenant as
currently in the lore they have an
attack to reach yet and while it didn't
take very long to get into a fight with
them the fact that bungie made it seem
like the covenant wouldn't show up yet
was a really good attempt at
storytelling as we continue through the
mission you'll notice reach takes a
different approach to its levels there
isn't some end goal of destroying the
halo ring or stopping the flood it's
just about defending reach and while the
player may be put into different
environments or different circumstances
it's always about defending reach it
isn't until the final few missions of
the game where this will change mobile
team is a team of spartans under the
command of colonel holland and then
eventually oni and pretty much anyone
else that is above them so they just do
as they're told after discovering
covenant presence on reach they report
back to colonel holland who sends them
to ony sword base to defend it after
this mission we just appear on a
cliffside with june with most of halo's
games especially the original trilogy
you're going from one place to another
but it's a natural flow from one mission
to the next that means the missions are
connected through each mission's actions
like in halo 2 where you go from the
metropolis level unearthed then another
halo ring right after it doesn't make
sense initially but the cutscene shows
that we hopped into the portal and
arrived on the other side reach has this
too but sometimes noble team just
appears in a completely new area it did
admittedly dampen the story for me a bit
at times but seeing as the overall
objective is to defend reach it can be
assumed that they don't stay in one
place as certain areas are more valuable
than others a good example is the
mission with june the whole point is to
go behind enemy lines and evaluate the
covenant's forces which we do by finding
the space at the end of the level so we
are doing what we set out to do in the
mission but nothing in the previous
mission from in-game events to the
cutscene afterwards implies that our
next stop is this random location on
reach and our next objective is to
infiltrate behind enemy lines it's only
until starting the mission and talking
with june that we understand our
objective despite how small this issue
may be to people can make the story seem
a bit disjointed thankfully it only
occurs in a small handful of levels
after discovering the covenant's main
base of operations we set out as an army
and attempt to defeat the covenant in
this battle noble team manages to
destroy the anti-air guns and larger
towers surrounding the covenant so that
a large frigate can come in and wipe it
out until it's interrupted by a larger
covenant carrier this ship possesses a
grave threat to noble team reach and the
unsc so it needs to be taken down the
unsc have the capabilities of destroying
it but it would cost thousands of lives
to even get a few shots at it kat uses
her knowledge of blacklisted intel from
oni to come up with a plan that involves
dropping a giant bomb onto the cruiser
so that it can go to the carrier and
blow it up that way this involves going
to an unmarked launch site from the
saber program and attacking the cruiser
from space this then leads into a string
of missions that are more or less about
helping people within those areas until
we reach the final mission starting with
the package noble team is instructed to
go back to oni and blow the building up
so the covenant can occupy the data
everyone on the team is on the same page
as they're confused why such a routine
demolition job is being tasked on
spartans as they approach the
coordinates they're taken to a secret
area in oni that leads to an underground
facility where dr halsey conducts her
research her research is an ai that is
the custodian of an ancient civilization
that a.i is cortana dr halsey wants us
to escort cortana to a ship-breaking
yard nearby and that ship which will be
going on is the pillar of autumn dr
halsey claims that the failure to
deliver cortana to the pillar of autumn
will be the loss of humanity this leads
to noble team defending the pillar of
autumn from an onslaught of covenant
forces and there's also an easter egg in
the cutscene as the right thumbstick is
enabled allowing you to peer over at the
master chief who's in the same pod as
the one from halo 1. so it was thanks to
noble 6 and the rest of noble team that
the master chief and cortana were safely
aboard the pillar of autumn which laid
to the events of the original trilogy
and the unsc defeating the flood the
prophet and starting a truce at the
elites all of this can be attributed to
the help of noble team on reach this
then seems like the end of the game
until the lone wolf mission starts and
ends up becoming a noble six's last
stand this is probably a good time to
bring up the main thing i've been
avoiding this whole time now it's no
secret that reach has a depressing
ending in which everyone on noble team
minus june dies every single one of them
is gut-wrenching even if it starts to
become old but besides their deaths in
general there is a lot of community
theories regarding them claiming that an
organization was hunting them from the
very beginning and that the way they
died in game is very ironic to their
skill set george's death is very common
in all types of media where a valiant
hero sacrificed themselves to complete
an objective or to save others this was
during the time that noble team was
trying to destroy that covenant carrier
this idea worked flawlessly except the
bomb timer is fried meaning it has to be
set off manually which causes george to
sacrifice himself and blow himself up
along with the covenant carrier george's
death was unexpected but nothing out of
nowhere as most deaths like this are
it's usually a slow build-up with some
final words and a last goodbye george
dying wasn't a tremendous loss compared
to others like cat or carter but having
one less gun on the team is still a
problem speaking of cat her death was
done exceptionally well prior to her
death the entire team was held up inside
a room where colonel holland wanted to
speak to carter on an open channel
usually you would avoid situations like
this as the enemy can tap into the
communications but given the
circumstances there wasn't any options
available right after this the team is
almost hit by a covenant glassing beam
and needs to evacuate the building once
they exit the elevators they run down
the hallway until cat walks in view of
an opening in the ceiling and is shot
through the head given how she died
there's no way this phantom just
strolled by and happened to see them
since the hole is so small even if that
was possible there's no way the zealot
would have had enough time to react on
how fast they were running this leads
many to believe that this was planned
and it was because of that call with
holland that the covenant were able to
find where they were some also believe
that noble six was followed and the
phantom was waiting for them to leave so
that they could be ambushed either way
cat's death was completely unexpected
seeing as only george at this point had
died the idea of everyone in the team
dying eventually didn't really settle in
yet and it was still quite the shock to
see something like this happen cat is
arguably the only one to not go out in
some heroic way just a shot to the head
i feel the same about carter's death
that i did with george when starting the
mission we can see that he's clearly
wounded and bleeding things aren't going
too great but considering he's a spartan
it's possible he could survive this but
as we're cornered by a scarab carter
says his final goodbyes around this time
it was quite obvious that the team was
dying one by one so it seems like it was
carter's time to go and while it was
definitely more expected than the others
as we had more time to digest the
situation at hand it doesn't take away
its emotional impact as though the team
is without its leader seeing as june had
disappeared in the previous mission it's
just emil and noble six two soldiers
without a leader but a clear objective
in mind emil will soon follow as while
defending the pillar of autumn a
covenant phantom drops a couple zealot
class elites on top of him but in this
case emile seemed alright no one has
ever survived to stab through the body
like that but seeing as he was able to
swing his body around and throw the
elite off the cannon with him it gives
the player some hope that he could still
be alive except when we arrive we can
see him dead on the railing emil was
always my favorite on the team so this
was upsetting seeing him die in the
final moments of the game but noble 6's
death is by far the most emotional as we
get to see the character we've been
playing as this whole time die in front
of us as we mentioned before the pillar
of autumn was the last ship off reach
and seeing as he had to man the mack
cannon he wasn't going to make it to the
ship the amount of phantom seen during
this sequence is astronomical the game
is trying to portray how many of them
are by throwing so many at you that it's
hard to keep up mobile 6 barely gave the
pillar of autumn enough time to launch
on its own so if he was to run and catch
a pelican the pillar of autumn would
have been destroyed a common criticism
i've seen about this last mission though
is why did noble 6 not run away why make
a last stand and a follow-up question i
have would be where reach is gone if
that ship was the last ship in the
continent off planet then reach is
totally screwed there is no saving this
planet or the lives on it anymore seeing
as noble 6 is now the last member of his
squad and is now stuck on a dying planet
filled with covenant that could be
glassed at any moment he decides to take
as many covenant down with him as he
could if you sustain enough damage your
visor will actually crack during this
fight which is an abrupt mechanic that
actually had me worried on my first
playthrough i figured this would be a
story of how everyone on noble team died
except noble 6 as we are the protagonist
but my heart dropped when those cracks
started appearing as it was telling me
that noble 6 isn't going to make it
while the fight will probably last you
minutes according to some within the
community it seemed that the fight
actually lasted for hours which would
explain how exhausted he looks in the
cutscene as he had been fighting
non-stop i can't find an actual source
to confirm this information but assume
this is true the master chief isn't the
only demon the unsc has in its ranks
mobile 6's death was a last stand as the
lone wolf the lone wolf of noble team
and the lone wolf of the unsc on reach
this leads into the massive theory
within the community that noble team was
being hunted by zealot elites in mission
2 as we continue to find the relay
station and we see the team get ambushed
by those zealots i talked about earlier
two of them go deeper into the structure
but you'll notice one escapes the other
way and is never seen again carter
brings this up to dr halsey back at oni
sword base and she explains how her and
some people at oni believe that the
covenant dispatch a small team of
advanced elite units so they can
retrieve artifacts of value to their
religion dr halsey believes that they
came to that station for the
intelligence that oni had stored there
this theory continues to explain certain
events that occur within the game seeing
as there's possibly dozens of these
zealot units it's safe to assume that
someone is commanding them it's a theory
that this elite who seems to be the
shipmaster of the covenant carrier is
the religious leader of the group and
seeing as we not only killed the leader
but blew up the ship it's possible that
they had marked us for death the entire
campaign the only evidence that supports
this theory is the zealot elites of the
same design are the ones who kill cat
emile and noble vi according to the lore
there are many different types of
zealots within the covenant and the
armor they wear as representative of
their fleet meaning anyone wearing this
purple and blue tint on their armor
belongs to the same group it's not
outlandish to think that this elite who
ran away told the others about what
happened and when the rest both heard of
the elite's reports and news of their
leaders deaths they immediately hunted
them down we see these elites everywhere
in the game and it's not that hard to
assume that they'd most likely be
communicating with one another and
gathering intel on our current location
it's an astounding theory with a decent
amount of evidence behind it many people
also believe that the elite who got away
in mission 2 is either the same one that
kills us or the one that we kill before
using the mack cannon which is an
interesting way of thinking about it
this leads me to another discovery
within the game and that's how ironic a
noble team's deaths are george was an
expert on big guns and explosives but
died from an explosion cat is smart and
incredibly intelligent with technology
but the one time she relaxes and allows
carter to talk on an open channel she
dies for it she is so self-aware of the
consequences that come from her actions
which is why she constantly attempts to
keep intel and communication secret but
the one time that they weren't she paid
the price for it carter is the leader of
the group and just like any other leader
of a ship goes down with the ship
literally emil was extremely proficient
in close quarters combat and was also
fascinated with knives the irony being
that he dies by an energy sword and
noble six from the very beginning of the
game was always alone he was described
as a lone wolf in his file and was
either the last surviving member of his
last squad or preferred to do missions
alone due to his expertise in combat
it's ironic that he died the way he
lived
alone even june's disappearance is quite
ironic as he's the sniper of the group
he's meant to not be seen and june is
never seen again after the mission with
dr halsey he just disappeared and left
without anyone knowing he was there just
like a sniper should due to how this
encompassed all of noble team i can't
see this being a coincidence and the way
bungie pulled this off without outright
saying it to the player is brilliant
storytelling halo reach was made with
the intention of creating more spin-off
content within halo but the team went
above and beyond with its gameplay and
story changes to make this one of the
best halo games of all time it had a
fantastic multiplayer and a brilliantly
written story with a plot to connect all
the games in the series and with enough
underlying themes in theories that it's
almost poetic
video game spin-offs have always been
hard to pull off they're going against
what the main series has spent years
establishing this either involves a
complete change of the game's core genre
or made with different ideas in mind
regarding its story this usually leads
to negative reception amongst the
community as not many games have good
spin-offs and even less games have
spin-offs that are great enough to rival
the main series but halo's spin-offs are
perfect they were created to be great
halo games with the intention of adding
more story and world building to the
game's universe by telling stories of
others during the human and covenant war
both games showcased the horror of the
covenant a city or planet's first
encounter with them or how its surviving
members took specific actions in an
attempt to stop them odst showed this by
having us play as a more human-like
soldier within the war truly is showing
us through gameplay how tough the
covenant were to fight and reach shows
its story through the eyes of one
spartan one who gets to see the
covenant's destruction firsthand as he
and the rest of the squad are attempting
to fight back against an army on a dying
planet that is inevitably going to fall
the story and the presentation of these
games is the reason i love them both so
much they were able to change the
formula of halo in both gameplay and
storytelling and still manage to
captivate the eyes of the community
however both games felt bittersweet as
they were able to end halo on a high
note but these were halo's last games
at least that's what we thought
when bungie announced in 2007 that they
were going to split away from halo
microsoft needed to find another team to
produce the games and in that same year
they created 343 industries 343 was
thankfully not starting from scratch
they were creating map packs for halo
reach and were also responsible for the
anniversary editions of halo 1 and 2.
however after bungie was finished with
reach all the rights went to 343 and
they began working on halo 4. seeing as
halo was now being developed by a
totally new company that means new
people were being added to the team all
directors producers writers programmers
artists and composers were changed
making it very clear that this would be
a very different halo halo 3's story
ended with the conclusion of the human
covenant war they joined together
against a common enemy and were able to
settle their differences the problem is
where do you go from here the original
trilogy wrapped things up rather nicely
but left out tons of info on the
forerunners which is where halo 4
started off we were now finally able to
see who the forerunners are why they
built the rings and what happened to
them the four runners from a story
perspective was a fantastic choice and
also just felt like the next step in the
timeline there wasn't much to go off of
so why not go back to the civilization
that has been talked about since combat
evolved thanks to this in the years of
established lore 343 had tons of
knowledge to use when creating their
story seeing as this game was focusing
on the forerunners that meant the design
team was starting from scratch the
4runners have only been talked about so
far within the games which is why the
design process for them took such a long
time to get right d43 took the style of
4runner architecture and used that to
develop the prometheans many forerunner
structures are large and able to defy
gravity which is why the prometheans are
of a similar build visually these
enemies are wonderful mechanically
they're a chore to fight their fighting
style is very collaborative the knights
can spawn watchers from their back and
the watchers can protect the knights
while also throwing grenades back if
they're within range of one if given the
opportunity they can even revive the
dead knight if possible the crawlers are
best suited alone but are very similar
to grunts as while one is no big deal a
group of them is very deadly this
dynamic forces you to find the weapon
with the most firepower rather than the
one they're weakest to the covenants
since halo ce have always been strong
but have their weaknesses plasma weapons
make an elite or jackal shield useless
and the firearms of the unsc are great
at taking down enemies without shields
it was this back and forth of combining
bold styles of weapons or using
different tactics to eliminate your
enemy's strengths the prometheans don't
have any weaknesses any possible
weaknesses are completely situational
crawlers will die to one shot in the
head but that's if you can aim well
enough to hit them while they're
charging you at full speed watchers are
vulnerable when reviving dead knights
but that's not a weakness more of a
beneficial feature of a rare situation
there is no counterplay to these enemies
it's just about putting as many bullets
into them as fast as possible and the
weapons they wield are just as
one-dimensional as they are every gun in
halo was designed around shooting and
doing damage but the covenant's weapons
were able to add that extra flair to the
weapons by trading ammo capacity for
cooldowns or having an additional effect
tied to the weapon like how the plasma
pistol can shoot down a vehicle or
eliminate an enemy shields none of these
weapons though promoted strategy they
just focused on damage and if they have
an additional effect it's all based
around damage it removes a core
principle of halo which was having a
balanced and engaging arsenal of weapons
that wasn't based on what you needed to
use but what you wanted to use i also
can't help but feel that 343 desperately
wanted to lower what was viable in halo
4 in regards to its weapons and
equipment a good percentage of the game
is centered around fighting promethean
so it's natural that there are weapon
lockers with promethean firearms near
their bases which means the player will
be using forerunner weapons for the
majority of their playtime i don't
really have too much of an issue with
this what i do have an issue with is
their changes to the other faction's
weapons the covenant is a laughing stock
compared to its previous iterations
elites are wiped out so fast that i've
never seen them as a threat anymore even
when i wasn't using a plasma pistol an
assault rifle had enough rounds in one
clip to take its health from 100 to zero
probably the hardest enemy to fight was
the jackal snipers as the new beam rifle
was actually a really nice change
focusing more on ammo capacity rather
than cooldowns however the other weapons
are a joke now they function exactly
like normal against the covenant but
against the prometheans most aren't even
worth using and seeing as you're
fighting prometheans for most of the
game there isn't many opportunities to
even use these weapons against them
there was only a handful of times where
both the covenants and the prometheans
were present which would allow you to
use their weapons against them but
seeing as the prometheans have no
counterplay it's all about doing damage
as fast as possible making half these
weapons useless anyway the unsc weapons
didn't get much of a change from its
previous installments but due to the
lack of unsc weapon lockers in the game
you'll end up running out of ammo really
quickly and being forced to use the
promethium weapons all this obviously
leads to the player having to rely on
the promethean weapons during most of
the combat throughout the game and since
the weapons do nothing but just do
damage and the prometheans have no
weaknesses it's just picking the highest
damaging weapon and shooting the enemy
closest to you this imbalance even
continues in the game's abilities halo 4
took some of reach's armor abilities and
even added a few original ones i'll be
completely honest with you half the time
i forgot these even existed the hologram
was fantastic and it made clearing areas
extremely easy but the rest were pretty
forgettable active camo replaced the red
enemies on the hud with blue markers and
when an enemy would get close to you
their marker would disappear that was a
key drawback on the active camo as it
would give you the invisibility but
would mess with your map so you weren't
at a complete advantage this completely
ruins the concept of active camo is even
if the enemy's marker disappears when
they get closer to you you still know
the direction they're in auto sentry and
hard light shield were extremely
situational and completely outclassed by
the hologram and the jetpack was also
pretty situational but in this case it
didn't really bother me because i've
always felt it to be pretty situational
anyway taking all this into account that
means you're left with very little
equipment to use and a small range of
weapons to use during combat that have
no way of outplaying the prometheans
other than shooting more bullets into
them halo force combat is leagues behind
its predecessors and shows a lack of
acknowledgement towards halo's core
foundations but at least its story is
better
sort of 343 took the liberty of making a
story about the prometheans and it was a
great idea as we discussed earlier the
lead director josh holmes wanted to make
more human elements to the story this
was accomplished by having a secondary
plot involving cortana and the master
chief the team thought this would be a
hard idea to sell especially when
introducing newer players into the story
but they decided to keep it anyway i
genuinely love this story between
cortana and the master chief the two are
an unstoppable force throughout the
series but now one of them is causing
both of them to fail within the first
mission cortana has a sort of weird
outburst something that's never happened
before after the two talk we discovered
that cortana has been in service for
eight years and after seven they start
to die and enter a stage of rampancy 343
did an excellent job conveying a sense
of progression throughout the story as
cortana every so often will have weird
glitches then move to the occasional
outburst to her not even listening by
the end of the game she starts to
realize the effects of her rampancy it's
not just affecting her but affecting
everyone around her this leads her down
a depressive state towards the end of
the game where she comes to terms with
her condition and reflects on her own
life telling the chief that it's
inevitable she'll be replaced but it's
possible with enough convincing she
could get dr halsey to make another
cortana but it wouldn't be the same this
was such a fantastic plot there was
progression and urgency as cortana was
slowly getting worse and worse which
showed the player how severe her
condition was but due to how great it
was it overshadowed the original story
you wouldn't be wrong if you thought
that halo 4 seemed like it was more
about cortana than the prometheans it's
a rare case of the side story being more
involved in the main plot i think a big
reason was the main plot about the
prometheans and the died act the
civilization who finally got screen time
in the latest entry compared to cortana
and the master chief who've been
inseparable since 2001. cortana's plot
is the overarching plot of the entire
saga but it still needs to tell a story
within each game within the original
trilogy cortana's plot is like the flood
something that exists from the beginning
but will be referenced in the later
entries until the very end of the saga
where it gets wrapped up the plot of the
died didact is just halo 1's story once
we discover the flood we try to leave
installation 0-4 as fast as possible and
end up blowing it up in the process the
story of the flood is still very much in
the works but installation 0-4 story is
finished this is the same for the didact
and cortana except with halo 4 343 tried
to do the same thing but make the plot
of the entire saga about two of the most
well-known characters in the game so
it's no wonder why people cared more
about them than the died act as we start
the game master chief wakes up four
years later from his cryogenic slumber
in halo 3. cortana senses something
wrong with the ship and wakes up the
chief because of it as we explore the
depths of the ship we come face to face
with our first enemy which is an elite i
like probably many of you were confused
as at the end of halo 3 the covenant had
a truce with the unsc that cortana and
master chief even mention this too this
whole plot never gets brought up again
in the entire game master chief never
asks cortana later in the game if she's
discovered more info and he never
bothered to ask anybody on the unsc
infiniti about this either the unsc
infiniti is a giant super carrier that's
been conducting missions to explore the
other halo rings for research and
decommission so they've been all over
the galaxy looking for these things if
you remember from the original trilogy
the covenant wanted to complete their
great journey which was to ascend to a
heavenly paradise and exist as divine
beings to do this they needed to
activate all the halo rings so if the
unsc is trying to study and put the
rings into decommission you would think
that the covenant would be extremely
pissed about this so how was the
infinity not run into any covenant at
all and even if they did why did master
chief and cortana not mention it why is
no one being brought up to speed at all
during this story the reason we aren't
told this is because technically we were
already told this in a book apparently
sometime after halo 3 and after the
peace treaty between the two species
some splinter groups of the covenant did
not appreciate the treaty and thus went
rogue forming their own faction this is
another instance of halo using the books
to explain a story this happened before
in halo 3 when the master chief ends
halo 2 on the forerunner ship then just
propels himself down to earth in halo 3.
back then it didn't bother me as it
wasn't that big of a deal this plot
however is literally a defining moment
in halo's universe and was the sole
reason for the trilogy to end something
like this cannot be simply resolved in a
book and even if it has to be it needs
to be explained to the players who only
play the games the books are there to
add more lore to the universe by showing
new short stories or adding just a small
amount of flavor to existing characters
it shouldn't be a requirement to read
the books to understand the story that's
what causes new people to care less and
less about the story since they need to
put in more effort to understand it at a
basic level the only thing left to
discuss is the didact like i said before
it felt like the plot with cortana was
overshadowing the died act towards the
end of the first mission the master
chief and cortana along with the unsc
forward unto dawn get sucked into this
giant structure and end up on a
forerunner planet called requiem after
exploring they hear a distress call from
the unsc infinity and eventually realize
that the infinity is trying to land on
the planet which is a terrible idea
considering the fact they don't know
about the prometheans yet this leads to
the master chief touching these pillars
in hopes of establishing contact with
them but it turns out that it was the
died act manipulating the signal to get
chief to open up the kryptom he was
stored inside he immediately overpowers
the master chief and mentions how the
humans will not be allowed to obtain the
mantle and that the forerunners have
returned this is a great introduction to
the died act and his motives and it was
presented really well he believes that
the forerunner should have kept the
mantle of responsibility and that the
humans did not deserve it this like the
covenant splinter group is something
mentioned in the books it's never
explained in halo 3 or halo 4 what the
mantle is why only a human can activate
the ark in halo 3 and why the humans are
the inheritors to the mantle once again
another part of halo's lore that
shouldn't be put into a book but
regardless we do understand his
intentions and it's our job to stop him
sometime later in the game we meet a
ghostly apparition of the librarian who
tells us about humanity the forerunners
and the died act essentially the died
act is trying to find the composer so he
can defeat the forerunner's strongest
enemy who is humanity long ago mankind
was traveling all over the galaxy and
was claiming land for itself until the
died act and his forces ended up
stopping them it was discovered way
later that after defeating mankind that
they weren't trying to expand and take
over people's land but they were running
away from another enemy that we know is
the flood we also discovered that the
composer would have been used to combine
the two realms of organic and digital
life but it failed causing those who
were affected by it to die the
forerunners then made their plans for
the final great journey but the didact
refused to give up the mantle of
responsibility which is why he was
imprisoned although it can definitely be
seen as a long cutscene full of
exposition i wasn't particularly annoyed
by it given the lore that we learned
from it a little later is when master
chief meets up with the members of the
infinity like palmer del rio and lasky
though rio was definitely written to be
an [ __ ] and they exceeded in doing so
despite the imminent threat that idax
poses del rio refuses to listen to the
chief which causes him to go on his own
this goes into a very long set of
missions of trying to destroy the
dieback's defenses and attempting to
hide the composer he ends up stealing it
and we get to see the true power he can
possess as he turns the crew of the
nearby station into ash we then get into
the last mission and discover that his
plan was to destroy earth with the
composer i said before that halo doesn't
have a great track record when it comes
to boss fights and this is by far the
worst in the series say what you will
about the weapon convenience of guilty
spark and the exploitative ai of
tartarus but at least you got to fight
them this entire campaign has led up to
this very moment with the didach seconds
away from destroying earth where we had
to battle through hundreds of
prometheans for him to only die by a
grenade and also die during a quick time
event i don't think i need to go into
detail how pathetic this is this whole
process of cortana splitting and using
her fragments of her mind to attack the
died act then dying from the chief after
a large boss fight would have been great
but the boss fight starts during the
cutscene and ends in two button presses
good riddance to the died act and good
riddance to his dull plot thankfully we
continue to further the plot of cortana
and we see that she used the last of her
fragments to save the qi from the
explosion but it pretty much killed her
this was such a touching moment as this
is the first time that cortana gets to
physically touch the chief and she also
calls him jon it seemed that the master
chief would be without cortana forever
and that was heartbreaking for both the
player and the master chief this seemed
like the first time ever that we would
never be able to see cortana again and
that was extremely touching halo 4 was
343's attempt at making a full game and
while it was a solid effort it's clear
that it didn't live up to the
expectations of many of its fans it had
boring and tedious firefights that
lacked the fundamentals of halo's core
combat and introduced a new enemy and
plot that was overshadowed by a side
story making the original story they
envisioned feel incompetent in
comparison with the studio being
completely focused on only making halo
games a sequel would easily be able to
iron out any issues the studio had with
its first attempt
halo 5 to this day remains the most
controversial halo game on this list the
amount of discourse and arguments that
have sprouted from this game is
incomprehensible due to the subpar story
of halo 4 many believe that 343 would
take in community feedback to find out
what they got wrong and fix the sequel
it's really hard to be thrown into a
series midway through its release
especially one as significant as halo
and expect to put out a quality game the
first time around it also didn't help
that they weren't able to build off much
of the original trilogy due to how much
that story wrapped itself up but this is
now their second attempt at making a
halo game they understand the workflow
the technology the lore and are now more
prepared than they were ever before to
make halo 5 but it still wasn't enough
in fact halo 5 seems to be going
backwards in terms of story progression
by rewriting things that occurred in the
previous game and then trying to spice
things up by adding more new ideas but
never developing them it seemed like 343
was trying to make the game accessible
to new players but at the same time make
it feel like it was only for the veteran
fanbase the gameplay and the flow of
combat is easily the highlight of halo 5
and was changed to be more accessible to
newer players 343 changed everything
wrong with halo 4 and made it way better
in halo 5. for a quick refresher from
the halo 4 section the main issues with
the combat was the forerunner weapons
were always based around damage with
very little gimmicks to set them apart
from one another the prometheans were
also really boring and it felt like 343
just added random types of enemies
anywhere they could due to the
collaborative nature of the prometheans
but more specifically the watchers they
made combat extremely tedious by
reviving dead knights and blocking
bullets from ever hitting them this was
made even worse when the health of the
watchers was higher than it needed to be
causing you to run out of ammo quickly
with no weapons to defend yourself
however 343 changed all of this not once
did i feel bored from its gameplay in
fact it was a breath of fresh air after
just playing through halo 4. the bolt
shot is now a three round burst and
carries more ammo the light rifle
regardless of whether you're aiming or
not is always single fire and the
suppressor is slower but it gets faster
the longer you hold the trigger down and
also seems to do more damage to the
prometheans as well both the bolt shot
and suppressor also track enemies when
your cursor is on them which is way
different from the piece shooter damage
of the bolt shot and the abysmal
accuracy of the suppressor by far the
best change was its enemy variety halo 4
suffered from making the prometheans
boring to fight then also making them 90
percent of the enemies you face
ultimately making all of its gameplay
awful but halo 5 introduced newer
prometheans and reintroduced the
covenant again and gave them more screen
time so it became a healthy balance of
both covenant and promethean combat the
knights were drastically changed in halo
5 as only a few show up throughout the
game but were made stronger as a result
the knights were replaced by much easier
and less damaging prometheans who are
called soldiers they have no gimmicks
like spawning enemies or being revived
they're just like the elites of the
covenant the standard soldier within the
army's ranks the knights sort of became
the brutes from halo 2 who only showed
up on occasion but eventually got worked
into the game's combat where you could
face three or four at a time the knights
can still spawn watchers and be revived
but they have weak points on their
bodies that will lower their health
greatly after both of these are
destroyed their only weak point left is
their face which is covered by a metal
mask but seeing as they're having a much
stronger role in this game i don't mind
a bit of difficulty to add to this the
watchers are much more doable this time
around being killed in a few shots by
just about any weapon and also use their
shielding and revive abilities very
sparingly it makes them just as
important as any other enemy in the
faction but doesn't make them too much
of an annoyance allowing combat to flow
from one area to the next without taking
10 minutes to clear a room as for the
covenant 343 reverted to the changes of
the plasma weapons as now they sound
like the originals and don't waste as
much ammo this makes covenant weapons
fun to use again and gives you an
opportunity to actually pick the weapons
you want and not start a scavenger hunt
trying to find a weapon what 343 really
nailed was the blending of combat
between these factions some missions
will just have covenant some will just
have prometheans but there are other
instances where both show up in the same
mission or even at the same time due to
the numerous changes 343 made in halo 4
it was tough to use covenant weapons
against promethean since ammo ran out so
fast and the promethium weapon seemed to
do no damage against the covenant if
they even showed up during a mission but
343 blended both the weapons and enemies
perfectly re-establishing that balance
of halo's weapons and for the first time
in 343 saga you could use the weapons
you wanted without sacrificing damage
and it was a great step in the right
direction another first for the series
was that each weapon had universal aim
even weapons such as the plasma pistol
that have never been given an aim button
were finally given one this is added to
most likely keep up with current trends
in the industry as many fps games at the
time have an aimed down sight mechanic
it was a great implementation and a
great addition to its combat as things
felt smoother it's wonderful to be able
to control your aim with all the weapons
and not have to use the thumb stick to
aim down sight anymore further the
player was also given thrusters to
either dash out of combat or thrust
themselves into an enemy the hud also
displayed the player's health on top of
their shield so you know exactly how
close you are to death and just in case
things did go wrong 343 allowed players
to be revived by their squad mates
everything added made its combat more
accessible and easier to use allowing
for a much more enjoyable experience if
there was ever a halo game that was able
to update its mechanics but also retain
halo's core values giving that rewarding
experience when playing it's halo 5. 343
finally nailed its combat and it's clear
that a lot of people loved it too as the
feel of its weapons is almost identical
in multiplayer which was nominated
numerous times in various award shows
its combat made the campaign a genuinely
fun experience assuming you tuned out
the story halo 5's story is where the
bulk of its criticism lies as i said 343
added tons of ideas and potential plots
to this game but never developed them
the end of halo 4 showed cortana
seemingly dying and never coming back
343 wanted to expand on this by quote
making a story that explores how the
master chief copes with the loss and
past memories this is a great idea and
what a lot of people expected to happen
given how the last game ended until this
idea was seemingly thrown out the window
by bringing her back in the first act of
the game how are you going to tell the
story about the master chief's loss and
the death of his friend if she's not
dead in the first place after the rescue
of dr halsey in mission 1 thanks to fire
team osiris who i will get to shortly
the team and her arrive back at the unsc
infiniti she's taken away from lasky by
spartan palmer and before she disappears
halsey asks what she has done and how
far she has gone the reason dr halsey
needed to be rescued was because she had
information on the recent attacks on
human colonies that were led by the
forerunners taking into account the
whole game's narrative it's clear that
the she she's talking about is cortana
which means she knows cortana's alive
and knows what she's capable of later at
the end of mission 2 halsey's conveying
tolaski the severity of the situation
and how she has access to the forerunner
domain and instead of listening to her
he and palmer ignore her fireteam osiris
has no idea what's going on in their
hunt or what cortana is even doing they
were just told by lasky to bring the
chief in thinking he's gone rogue in
search of her this game is withholding
so much information from its cast of
characters why hasn't halsey shared what
the domain is what the guardians are and
even more importantly this line in the
beginning means she knows that cortana
is alive and refused to tell anyone
especially jon furthermore why is lasky
of all people not hearing what she has
to say if this whole plot is revolved
around cortana why would lasky refuse to
listen to the one woman who knows
cortana the most like i said before the
idea of making a game about the master
chief and the loss of his best companion
but then completely ruining that by
bringing her back makes no sense the
master chief isn't grieving anymore or
impacted by the loss in fact this
discovery motivates him to go find her
because who wouldn't in his situation
what doesn't make this any better is
that at the end of mission 2 the master
chief reports to infinity that he has
possible info and a location on cortana
but his orders are denied claiming that
another team is already handling it this
sets off numerous red flags for both the
player and even blue team they are
practically forcing the master chief to
go rogue from this blue team can assume
that the infinity knew about cortana and
had already planned to send a team to
find her instead of letting the literal
one person that she will always talk to
to handle the mission instead can you
see how confusing this must be for blue
team so of course they went to go find
her first master chief and the rest of
blue team are a family to cortana so
they have her best interest at heart and
are still willing to constantly talk to
her about what's going on no one else in
the unsc has that bond with her so blue
team is worried that they'll try to shut
her down without being able to see her
again how lasky and the others on the
infinity can force master chief to go
rogue and then literally complain when
he does exactly that is completely
bizarre to me as we continue into
mission 3 it's very clear that fire team
osiris is tasked with bringing in blue
team and here is where other numerous
criticisms start firstly 343 tried to do
what halo 2 did by introducing a new
protagonist in the form of spartan lock
but ultimately failed due to the next
problem a lack of development and
diversity the only character with any
sort of development on both teams
besides the master chief is buck we
already know who buck is thanks to halo
odst and we can now see that he's a
spartan he still uses the odst helmet
and occasionally references his time in
the odst saying that it was much easier
back then however what bothers me is the
lack of diversity these teams have
throughout the game i was genuinely
trying to find differences between any
of them and i still can't each of them
carry different weapons but all act the
same as we discussed in the halo reach
section despite all of noble team being
great at combat carter was an excellent
leader and kat was very smart with
technology none of these people exhibit
any defining qualities with the slight
exception of vale from fire team osiris
who was fluent in sangheili it's hard to
see them as a team when they can do the
same things having cat die showed a
weakness in noble team as their master
hacker was gone and when carter died
their leader was gone they lost a
critical part of the team but with
osiris and blue team if one of them were
to die it would just be one less gun in
a fight you could argue it's just the
same as emil or george as they were just
proficient in specific areas of combat
but from what little we see of them we
discovered that george had a friendly
relationship with dr halsey and he was a
part of the spartan 2 program and that
emil had a fixation with knives and
comes to accept death even in his final
moments even if they didn't have a
unique job on the team we still learn a
lot about them and it felt like 343 was
going somewhere when they touched on val
and her knowledge of elite language but
it just ends there this never really
gets developed or utilized and none of
the other members get large sections of
their stories uncovered it's not until
the final mission where cortana drops a
sentence of info about them minor
tangent aside if we return to where we
left off both buck and locke are
discussing the upcoming mission and how
lots of people will hate them for this
lock doesn't seem to care but it's clear
that it's very much affecting buck lock
plans to use this new armor locking
technology to sort circuit the armor
systems making it easier to retrieve
them the team then ends up heading to
meridian to find blue team as this is
the place cortana mentioned in chief's
vision as we go further into the colony
we discover a quarry that holds a large
forerunner structure which introduces us
to the warden eternal who claims to
stand in service to cortana this is
another huge drop of story for the
player as it seems that she is most
definitely working with the prometheans
and that the warden led blue team enter
the structure once again more story
potential and it was very well presented
eventually both teams come face to face
with each other and we get the infamous
chief and lock fistfight the
choreography in the fight itself was
pretty great it's quite rare to see two
spartans go head to head with their
fists so i was all for it my only
problem is the rest of osiris i've tried
to see this platform from all angles in
this cutscene and it does seem like this
jump is doable considering the other
things they've jumped from so why isn't
anyone on the team doing anything they
literally watched their leader lose and
then watch their mission objective
escape even if we were to play devil's
advocate and claim that the jump was
impossible they could have easily shot
him for resisting or fired warning shots
to distract him momentarily on top of
that shouldn't the other team members
have these armor locks even if they
didn't know the master chief was alone
who carries only one of these and never
has a backup it just seemed like locke
was so overconfident in his mission that
he brought only one and thought he could
1v1 the literal savior of humanity locke
was even gonna pull his gun on him too
which is more than enough reason for the
other members to do it too it just feels
like 343 wanted the player to focus on
the cool fight scenes and not the
questionable decisions surrounding it
it's after this part in the story where
i will completely admit
i'm a bit confused as we discover right
after the fight the guardian they've
been searching for wakes up and starts
attacking the colony while this is
happening blue team goes to the
teleporter and arrives at genesis
another 4runner planet everyone on blue
team is still unsure what cortana wants
with them and what she's doing which is
why they're continuing to pursue her in
hope of answers when they finally
managed to talk to her through the
communication she goes on to explain
that she found a cure for her rampancy
and that the cure can make ais immortal
it's because of their immortality that
the ais can now be the owners of the
mantle of responsibility while this does
sound great the master chief explains
that the mantle of responsibility is an
imperial piece meaning you either have
to do as they say or you suffer chief
doesn't like the idea of this and
conveys that to cortana who tells them
to come meet in person so she can
explain more this is another instance of
the game delaying information the game
keeps forcing the player to continue so
they can finally understand the story
it's not until mission 14 the second
last mission in the game where we find
out that cortana's plan was to use the
guardians to reinforce peace across the
galaxy like the forerunners did it took
14 missions to get that answer and
ironically enough cortana wanted to tell
blue team this in person but she still
did it over the comms anyway making this
whole weight pointless blue team will
eventually come face to face with her
and the master chief and cortana talk
out their differences cortana explains
that what she's doing is giving people a
gift and a way to be more than what they
currently are master chief can help but
relate to how halsey did this exact same
to him and the other spartan twos it's
clear neither side is in budging on
their stances so she locks him in a
kryptom and plans to release them once
peace has been brought to the galaxy
fire team osiris attempts to free them
which they succeed in doing but more
importantly during this sequence we hear
cortana call out to all the ai in the
galaxy to join her side and hundreds of
voices can be heard she even calls out
to all the other species in the galaxy
to join her this is an excellent
continuation of the saga because if the
ai are revolting then all the ships and
the colonies they belong to will most
likely shut down causing mass panic this
is exactly what we see in the final
moments of the game as roland is
reporting numerous distressed calls from
earth and the other colonies about this
exact problem then cortana shows up and
attempts to destroy them with her
guardian infinity escapes but they
assume cortana could track them easily
so they do random jumps across the
galaxy which is probably how we ended up
at zeta halo for halo infinite if things
in this section seemed somewhat rushed
you're not wrong most of it is due in
part to the story itself being quite
rushed but the other reason is because
this is the first time in this series i
am genuinely confused on what's going on
i've understood every halo game story
and plots but i cannot wrap my brain
around this the game threw so many
different things at the player in such a
short amount of time that it was
incredibly hard to keep up things like
the domain the guardians the word and
eternal and numerous other things were
mentioned earlier in the game but were
never explained until the very end it's
just an overload of information because
now the player has to learn new lore on
top of the new concepts they just heard
about while also trying to remember what
the other concepts they learned early in
the game were and try to piece all of
this together i literally didn't
understand until the last cutscene that
the created was something cortana came
up with i just figured this was
something the warden taught her or
something she found in the domain i
didn't realize that was the name of
their new faction hopefully though halo
infinite continues to run with this
rogue ai plan for its story as this is
starting to go in a really good
direction but the rest of the story like
lock and chief's conflict and all this
running around they do in the different
colonies is just as boring as the died
act halo 5 suffered from a rushed and
overwhelming campaign and attempted to
introduce new ideas and plots but either
didn't develop them enough or withheld
information from the player until the
very end overwhelming them with all of
it despite this its gameplay was greatly
improved and made combat in between its
story bits wonderful culminating in a
very interesting experience
despite its ups and downs halo will live
on as one of the most recognizable
franchises of all time it's still to
this day a revolutionary game that tries
to push its boundaries with every
release the original trilogy is
incredibly iconic and filled with some
of the franchise's best moments its
spin-off games were able to do what not
many could and be just as great as the
originals and even 343 is showing
incredible potential as they're slowly
but surely nailing the halo formula
while some games may be viewed better
than others it's without a doubt one of
the best games of all time with that
though we've come to the end of all the
halo games and subsequently the end of
the video thank you all for making it
this far this did take quite a bit of
time to make so if you enjoyed then
please make sure to leave a like if you
did and subscribe if you're new be on
the lookout in the coming weeks for the
halo infinite review but to tide you
over i have some wonderful videos like
my analysis on fallout new vegas and
prey and you can even check out my
reviews on ubisoft's newest titles
riders republic and far cry 6. thank you
once again for watching the video and to
my returning viewers i thank you for
coming back take care everyone
and goodbye
[Music]
you